[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: As enterprises move
their applications and services
to the Cloud, developers need
to evaluate and experiment
with new technologies
and tools to figure out
what works best for them.
This evaluation
process includes tasks
like identifying which
Cloud provider to use,
trying out new products, and
learning how to use new APIs.
However, we know from
talking with developers
that this initial evaluation
and setup phase often
takes longer than expected.
Maybe you run into problems
while getting your development
environment set up, like
finding the right libraries
and dependencies.
You probably don't
want to spend hours
trying to install
all the right tools
or trying to figure out why
the code works on your friend's
machine, but not yours.
Even after setup,
switching back and forth
between documentation, your
IDE, your terminal window,
and your Cloud
console can get messy.
This is where Cloud Shell
Editor comes into play.
Cloud Shell provides you
with command line access
to your Cloud resources
directly from your web browser.
And Cloud Shell
Editor, available
at ide.cloud.google.com,
extends Cloud Shell
with an online
development environment.
Powered by the Eclipse
Theia IDE platform,
Cloud Shell Editor makes it easy
for you to write code directly
from your web browser and
deploy it to the Cloud.
This online
development environment
comes packed with
powerful features
to streamline your
development workflows.
First, Cloud Shell Editor
integrates Cloud Code,
a set of IDE plugins that
help you stay productive
when developing
cloud-native applications.
Cloud Code simplifies Kubernetes
and cloud-run development
workflows.
It allows you to build, deploy,
and debug your application
in just a couple of clicks.
It also comes packaged with
container tools, like minikube,
Skaffold, Buildpacks, and Jib.
And with its API Explorer,
discovering, enabling,
and adding Cloud APIs to
your application is easy.
Cloud Shell Editor also has
version control and support
for multiple projects,
making it easy for you
to collaborate with teammates.
Cloud Shell Editor also
has rich language support
from many popular
programming languages
to make it easy for you to
write functional, clean,
and beautiful code.
To help you get started, we have
online interactive tutorials
to get you up to speed.
You can try some of our Cloud
Shell Editor Quickstarts
for Google Kubernetes
Engine and Cloud Run.
With Cloud Shell Editor,
we want to make it easy
for you to explore new Cloud
technologies, prototype
applications, and do
development tasks directly
from your web browser.
Check it out at
ide.cloud.google.com.
Let us know what you think, and
stay tuned for more episodes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]